Oh hello! How y- *gunshot*
Don'-
*Demonic screeching* AAAHH
Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome to "Our Own Light" Now this is, uh, chapter one of
an interesting looking game, I'm not entirely sure if it's absolutely horror or if it's some sort of
exploratory adventure game... "Before the Incident Wednesday August 24 2007"
Okay.
*Alarm blaring* Whoa- gah- oOokay
Oooh
LET'S GET THE FUCK OUTTAA HERE
I dunno what we're getting out the fuck of but-
Oh.
HOW
How do I lea-
OOH. Shit dude.
"Please evacuate this building."
Is that a baby crying?
Dude, I don't know how am I a baby? I'm so damn low
"Please evacuate this building."
Dude, again like I said I don't what's happening!
Oka- *Boom*
Ah, oh alright then, explode.
Sure, and then jump forward ten years.
Fuente Castilla's Building
Well that was about the most hype entrance to a game I've seen in a while
Ah.
Oh.
Find a comfortable place to work at. Is that my objective?
Okay, all right. Hello! Hi! This looks comfy oh, I can imagine working on a couch
"Work here" ahhh
Oh, yeah.
I didn't know we were gonna be soothed by smooth jazz-
oOkay.
*Eerie noises*
Uhh...
Is my TV bleeding all over my face?  I can't move, I think.
*Reading screen*
*Phone vibrating*
I have no idea whats ha- I'm so confused right now
But I'm not opposed I guess
Can I-
Can I get up?
Is this where I get up or is this where I just wait sum more?
*A voice message plays* "Hey buddy, I was just calling to see how much you had
progressed after.. What happened.
In your office last night."
"I know you have been very busy lately.
So I just wanted to let you know that that rehearsal,
our daughter has been practicing and
anticipated so much is tonight
but I know you wouldn't be able to come so,
don't worry.
She knows too, she understands.
There was something else I-
Oh, Yeah by the way,
The electricity company failed on us again,the light switches from upstairs and downstairs are not working
but somehow the lights from our bedroom are still working
so if you're hungry and want to go to the kitchen or something,
I left you a flashlight in our closet so you can use that."
Okay "If you need any help,
just call, if I don't answer it means
our daughter's show has started
I will get to you eventually so,
Love you. <3"
Okay, love you too. Bye. Bye smooches. Oh
The hell was that? Was that our daughter? Alright also
I'm confused *Squeak*
Those door sound effects,*giggling* those door sound effects really immerse me in this experience here.
Ah, yes.
Great
Okay, so whyyy?
Am I-wait a minute, wait?
Wait, I-wait a minute...
The layout of this house is exactly the same as Mortem.
I ju- I just
Connected that. No, this house is exactly the same, this hallway is the same, is this the same?
Yes, It's the same!
Is this a continuation of Mortem?, or is this just a-
wHAT IS SQUEAK SQUANKING?!
*Music playing and squeaking noises*
(Jeepers Creepers?)
*Men singing* "I don't care what the weather man says when the weather man says it's raining.
You'll never hear me complaining.
I'm certain the sun will shine. :)"
Ugh *Music still playing :)*
Locked, maybe the keys upstairs. Oh the back door is locked from the INSIDE.
Oh that makes sense. Oh that does make sense, okay? I like the way that is, where is the basement?
Ah, Is this the basement?
Or is it the garage?
*Radio* "Welcome  back to *something* with Gary Huntsman."
"We recieved some news of a
girl being sighted alone in the street near-"
*dunNNn* Ah-
pbbbbbbbbbbbBBBT
"Some rumors say that there was a girl that was trapped inside it while it happened
Reports say that when they wanted check with her. She randomly disappeared
nobody can explain the scene or cure but so far everybody was just replanted by them"
*More beautiful music*
Okay!
That's nice you talked about a mysterious little girl, and you left me alone it-  oOokay. That's different now
Ahh
Righty-ho then right-he-heHEE hi ho
This door seems to be stuck. Someone's trying to help me on the other side by BASHING IT OPEN I DON'T LIKE THAT!
mmM. I don't like this at all. I don't know what I'm- What are we doing here? Hi
Okay, you keep at that one though. I'll just stay up here and cower
Pray for my family because uh ooh uhh
You could stop that any day now. OOOh
Oh, hi. "Now you will die SMILEYFACE :)." Well. He's sure happy about it
*nervous laughing*
wait, oh I get it.
Thing on my phone. It wasn't a phone call. It was a voice message that I was listening to
a pre- oh, hi, okay? Oh, uh oh this, okay?
I was listening to it over to hear the voice
To hear the voice of my family and they died
And it's my daughter trying to get veNGEANCE UPON ME?!
HII!
OOOOH NOO
OOOH NOOOO
*click click* we're okay
Hi!
Oh! Ah, I'm here now. Hellooo, hi. How you doing?
*screaming noises*
wHAT?!
WHAT?! nOO
NO YOU CAN'T DO THAT!
Goddammit! This is chapter one not a demo!
I'm heartbroken you can't just bring it to the most good juicy part, and then just LEAVE ME BLUE BALLED!
UGH. Okay, so I couldn't leave you with that again. It was too short not enough happened
So I've got another Demo here of a horror game now hopefully
Something more happens here because I did see that there might be
Mannequins in this one and as much as I don't like Mannequins. I know that you guys
Know I don't like Mannequins and sometimes that's more imp- oweeh oh, hi
uGH gotta sQUINT WITH
MAH EYES!
Hello.
okay, ah
Good a door- hi?
HUHH I gotta squint, I can't see it come closer! Come into my loving arms!
HELLO?!
Hidey-Hidey-ho Who are you? Why are you just sitting there with an apple? Oh?
Don't get up. Don't get up! Don't get up you don't need to get up! Hi. Hello. Are you from Second Life?
I'll take it I guess okay. I'll take the apple. Okay, I ate it. It was delicious. Who dat behind you? oh- *gunshot*
I didn't see the gun at first. Ooh, great, okay
*gunshot*
Well this is off to a great start.
Now I'm going through the 2001 a space odyssey Tunnel
WHAT THE HELL?!
I mean that's a hell of an opening. I'm not complaining about that. Okay. Yes, sure. UHH LET ME SQUINT! WHAT'S OVER THERE?
HI!
Okay, sure
Ugh, this is creepy. Oh.
What is this? Oh. What's going--
oh, okay, a choice? It's the Stanley parable all over again.
Hi, Mr Eyeball, how you doing over there?
*"Soft squishy sounds"*
Ugh, I don't like the soft Squishy sounds
Hello? Oooh
Ah, good. I guess I won't go through that one. You know I was thinking about it
Bashing my head up against a brick wall for a few hOURS
Ya know i thought-
Hi? Are you something?
Something behind me? whew
Oh, no, that's something oh, hi. Hello. Yeah, don't get up dON'T GET UP!
MMm. Hey, where'd you go?
Alright
Still there? Am I just gonna trip on you? I don't have a flashlight. Okay. ugghh
Uggh, It's a different concept of going down hallways cuz I can't see what's that the eND OF THE HALLWAY!
Hi, hello, who are you? Nice ass, okay. Don't turn around don't get up hi. Hello Need some help there?
phuu- don't know what's goin' on.
Hello?
OH, Hi. Okay. Hello, everybody in here ah great good cool stuff
Ah,
So, uh, How we all doing?
How you guys doing you do- you good?
Y'good?
You guys look good
Hi, okay, you're close.
Ha, I  sAID DON'T GET UP!
OH no, I don't like that.
I don't like that at all.
Hi, okay.
*SCREECHING* HAAAII oKAY.
Okay, great. Whyy?  wHyy? wHY?
Oh, I got my bear repelling circle wait. That's a circle fro-
*Something breaks*
That was from the movie Arrival is what I was trying to say there, whoa. Hey
Okay, then
Alright
Cool. I'll go down this hallway sure yeah, that sounds like what I want to do great. Cool. Yeah, cool. Yeah great, okay?
Okay, I'll go left this time
Just cuz I feel like it. I don't know what's gonna mean for me, but I'll go that way
ugHH
goodness gravy
ay ay ay ay ay ay
Hello? helloo? Oh this how it wouldn't matter though. They were both down the same hallway
Great.
OH, Hi, didn't- almost didn't notice you there from the sounds coming off that way
Alright, cool you're doing great with whatever it is that you're doing
Could you allow me some time alone? And you go fuck off and die that'd be great too
Wait excuse you? excuse you? excuse you? Wanna go bro?
Ooh
That guy farted himself out of obliviON
Hello?
Very-okay, it's dark in here. Ah-oh!
Okay
Alrighty then, where are we now?
Why hello hi. How are you doing great? That's cute
Nice paintings, ah
Good. Still can't see right. Still a little blurry down there, but that's alr-
*clank* Hi.
How you doing? you good? you good bro? You good? Oh! This one might be my faVORITE
Good
Shit dude, welp, in Darkness again!
Aaah!
Really, that's what it's no, I locked okay? OHH!
More art it's like I'm in the museum of the Macabre
the Macabrrre
Oh, boy. Where you taking me?
I mean if there was ever a game. Oh, oh hey. Hey handsome. Ha ha are you doing?
Okay
Well, I'm ugly. "No one here get out alive."
I-I think I might be already dead so I think getting out alive at this point is the least of my concerns
How can I get out alive when there's no door?
Someone behind me now?
Okay, I know you're gonna play this game. I've seen this game many many times in my previous life
Yeah, usually starts and ends with me being jump scared, but oh
Now there's a door
I like that
I like that real good.
Oh, Yes, I'll stand in the closet and wait for it to change again. Thank you. Yes, I'll do that
Okay, where am I now okay? Ah.
There's the door. We just have to turn a little bit let my eyes adjust to it, and then you,
Okay, well ah yes great cool awesome
fantastic oh hello, hey-
*gunshot*
don't-
*demon screeching* AAAAHHH
hEEEYYY
Didn't think so. I didn't think so I didn't think so
I didn't think so if you want to mess with me you Gonna get the horns
I don't know what that means, but I've heard of it as an expression before and I think it means fUCK YOU.
Ah, Can't even see in this one just gonna trust this Gonna trust
OOOOKAY
Okay, that's the end of that.
Alright!
So there you have it. There you have it! Another double feature for you guys and not too shabby it weren't
So that was Nomed, and that was Out of Light. I like the option of doing these double features because it showcases these
Interesting concepts because this was a demo and that was a demo and each of them had something going for it
But wasn't quite there this one had something going for it. I like the
Blurriness of the Hallway the unseeing the walking slowly like it was good
But it wasn't like fully there the other one liked it at the ambience it had the idea the story was there
But it wasn't it didn't close it off
So thank you everybody so much for watching you can check out both of these games through the links in the description below
This one's apparently going on greenlight
And just thanks for watching let me know what you thought of these down in the comments below
I know there's potential in these the developers just got to take a few more steps
Further before I'm really sold on the idea, but good potential so far
So thank you again everybody and as always I will see you in the next video
Buh- bye!
*Rad outro music* :)